dis moi tu sais ce qui t'attend la folie
shit et se retrouver tous les deux dans
un coin sombre merde professional oui
c'est vrai puis tu me suis dit avec
celle intervenu pour pc
quels sont tes tabou se dit je ne
rigolerai jamais avec la religion et le
sida 1
c'est à dire que jamais parce que ça me
fait pas rire mais c'est pas dit à bout
je crois que j'ai aucun tabou il n'y a
rien que je suis au courant de rien
éviter mais il ya des choses qui ne font
pas rire comme le sida ça fait parler
parce que parce que ça fait peur et la
religion toujours pas comment je crois
en rire quoi je parle j'ai plutôt contre
1 chez vraiment unis soit serge c'est un
pas que je crois qu'il n'existe pas
celle que je crois que s'il est là je
vois pas sa place en tout cas pas vrai
parce qu' à quoi il sert bien mais
jamais fait fleuret par l'idée de
l'existence de dieu
non ça m'aide pas de savoir qu'il ya
quelque chose après donc quelqu'un qui
m'attend après donc quelqu'un qui est
plus fort que jamais besoin de savoir ça
c'est l'homme le plus fort puisque tu le
regrette mais bon c'est ça ouais un an
non parce que du coup je suis mon propre
dieu et j'ai pas seulement une force ça
me donne un caractère de 20,4 chaud
quand ton père est mort peut être tentée
de trac rocher à l'idée de l'existence
de dieu
non non je commence c'est drôle
conceptrice que maintenant il manque
maintenant sur le coup je pars demain
réaliser quoi sur coup c'était c'était
quelqu'un j'étais triste pour l'homme
mais l'agrandir la l'autorité garder cet
exercice verne faisait nos peurs et et
quand elle n'a plus été là quelque part
je me bats et des mois à je me suis dit
qu'il n'y aurait plus jamais personne
qui nous restent bas froid puisque
malheureusement ces personnes n'étaient
plus là mais bon et c'est maintenant par
contre que je me mets à pleurer dans un
feu rouge que je dis merde [ __ ] s'ils
étaient là pour voir ce qu'il n'arrive
serait fier